This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Let's say you make $500,000 a year. That puts you in the top 1% of all Americans, and far ahead of almost everyone else in the world. That's out the right center field again at the scene. What if that $500,000 salary comes from being a professional baseball player. For the Los Angeles Angels.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。假设你年薪50万美元。这让你跻身于全美前1%的行列，也远超世界上几乎所有人。这又回到了现场的右中外野。如果这50万美元的薪水来自一名职业棒球运动员呢？为洛杉矶天使队效力。
When you look over your shoulder in the locker room, you see this other guy, Mike. Two potential news now of the biggest contract in baseball history. Today, we learned that LA Angel's star, Mike, trout is finalizing a deal to stay with that team for another 12 years and to earn $430 million over that time. 430 million dollars over 12 years or 36 million dollars a year, which makes your $500,000 look measly. As we walk through the world, we are constantly comparing and contrasting our lives with those of others. We think about ourselves in terms of being on a certain wrong with some people above us and other people below us.
当你在更衣室里环顾四周，你会看到另一个人，迈克。现在有两条关于棒球史上最大合同的潜在新闻。今天，我们得知洛杉矶天使队的明星迈克·特劳特正在敲定一份合同，将继续留在该队12年，并在此期间赚取4.3亿美元。12年4.3亿美元，也就是一年3600万美元，这让你的50万美元看起来微不足道。当我们行走在世间，我们不断地将自己的生活与他人进行比较和对照。我们根据自己在阶梯上的位置来思考自己，有些人高于我们，有些人低于我们。
Where we think we stand on that ladder tells you a lot about a person's life and their life outcomes. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of inequality. How our predisposition to compare ourselves to others affects our minds and our bodies. Keith Payne is a psychologist at the University of North Carolina. He is the author of the Broken Ladder, How Inequality Effects the Way We Live, Think, and Die. Keith, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. I want to begin with a personal story that you've told in the book and elsewhere, Keith. This goes back to your childhood when you were in the fourth grade.
我们认为自己站在阶梯的哪个位置，能反映出一个人生活的很多方面及其人生结果。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨不平等的心理学。我们与他人比较的倾向如何影响我们的思想和身体。基思·佩恩是北卡罗来纳大学的心理学家。他是《破碎的阶梯：不平等如何影响我们的生活、思考和死亡》一书的作者。基思，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请。基思，我想从你在书中和其他地方讲过的一个个人故事开始。这要追溯到你上四年级的时候。
You were standing in line at a cafeteria in your school and you had your first visceral experience with the awareness of inequality. Tell me that story. What had happened was we had a new cashier, a new lunch lady in the line that day. When I got to the cashier's desk, she asked me for, I think it was $1.25. That was the first time that anybody had ever asked me to pay for my lunch because I had always been on free lunch and but I didn't know it because nobody
你当时站在学校食堂的队伍里，第一次有了关于不平等的直观体验。讲讲那个故事吧。那天发生的事情是，我们排队时来了一位新收银员，一位新的午餐阿姨。当我走到收银台时，她向我要了1.25美元，我想是这个数。那是我第一次有人要求我支付午餐费，因为我一直吃的是免费午餐，但我自己并不知道，因为从来没有人
had ever pointed it out or talked about it. And previously the cashier had just waved me on as part of the normal process but this new person didn't know how things worked and so she asked me to pay for my lunch and there was this awkward moment. I didn't have any money of course and I didn't know what to do about it and so that moment of awkwardness made me suddenly realize that wait some of these kids have been paying for their lunch all along and some of us haven't. And all of a sudden it dawned on me why that was, that we got free lunch, that meant that we were the poor kids, and that that had never occurred to me before. And so that awkward moment standing in the lunch line suddenly increased my awareness of
指出过这一点或谈论过它。以前收银员只是作为正常流程的一部分挥手让我通过，但这个新来的人不知道流程是怎么运作的，所以她让我付午餐费，当时出现了一个尴尬的时刻。我当然没带钱，也不知道该怎么办，所以那一刻的尴尬让我突然意识到，等等，原来有些孩子一直都在付午餐费，而我们中的一些人却没有。突然间我明白了原因，我们吃免费午餐意味着我们是穷孩子，而这一点我以前从未想到过。所以，站在午餐队伍里的那个尴尬时刻，突然增加了我对
not only the inequality in my classroom, but the implications of what it meant to be one of the poor kids. And so I started thinking about myself differently. I started seeing my friends and my peers differently. And all of a sudden, this relative difference between me and the other free lunch kids versus those who paid for their lunch, all of a sudden loomed larger than it ever had before, at least for me. And the interesting thing is, you know, that it's not like I was poorer the day after that than I was before. Nothing objectively had changed, but because of that subjective awareness, now everything
不仅是我班级里的不平等，还有身为穷孩子意味着什么的理解。于是我开始以不同的方式看待自己。我开始以不同的方式看待我的朋友和同龄人。突然间，我和其他吃免费午餐的孩子与那些付午餐费的孩子之间的这种相对差异，对我来说变得比以往任何时候都更加突出。有趣的是，你知道，并不是说那天之后我比以前更穷了。客观上什么都没有改变，但因为那种主观的意识，现在一切
seemed different to me. I want to talk about a wonderful analogy that you've explored in the book, and it really grows out in some ways of this conversation we're having about what happened in your school lunch cafeteria. Let's say I'm boarding a plane, and on my way to seat 36J in economy as I make my way down the aisle of a traditional plane, tell me what I see and how that affects me. So usually you enter at the front of the plane and you're walking down the aisle past the first class section with the large seats in the leg room and everybody's already settled in because
对我来说似乎都不同了。我想谈谈你在书中探讨的一个精彩类比，它在某种程度上源于我们正在进行的关于你学校午餐食堂发生的事情的对话。假设我正在登机，在前往经济舱36J座位的路上，当我沿着传统飞机的过道走时，告诉我我看到了什么，以及这对我有什么影响。通常你从飞机前部进入，沿着过道走过头等舱区域，那里有宽大的座位和腿部空间，每个人都已经安顿好了，因为
they boarded first. And you're walking past that to go to where I usually sit, which is in coach, right? So as you go to find your way, you're literally walking along this sort of status hierarchy, this laid out in front of you. And so there's the wonderful study that shows the psychological and behavioral consequences of experiencing that kind of hierarchy embedded in the airplane. The researchers looked at data from millions of flights to look at what predicted incidents of air rage, that is cases where passengers were unruly or disruptive or violent in some
他们先登机了。你走过那里去往我通常坐的地方，也就是经济舱，对吧？所以当你寻找座位时，你实际上是在沿着这种地位等级走，它就摆在你面前。有一个很棒的研究显示了在飞机上体验这种等级制度的心理和行为后果。研究人员查看了数百万次航班的数据，以观察是什么预测了空中愤怒事件，也就是乘客在某种程度上
way. And they found that in planes that had a first-class cabin, incidents of air rage were several times more likely to happen than in flights that didn't have a first-class cabin, which suggests that to witness that inequality seems to have some kind of psychological effect on people that really ramps up the disruptive behavior. to witness that inequality seems to have some kind of psychological effect on people that really ramps up the disruptive behavior.
变得不守规矩、具有破坏性或暴力的情况。他们发现，在有头等舱的飞机上，空中愤怒事件发生的可能性比没有头等舱的航班要高出几倍，这表明目睹这种不平等似乎对人们产生了一种心理影响，从而加剧了破坏性行为。目睹这种不平等似乎对人们产生了一种心理影响，从而加剧了破坏性行为。
Now it's worth noting that planes with a first-class cabin might be larger with more passengers and longer flights. More people and more time spent in the air could also increase the likelihood of air rage. But there are some other indications that seeing the inequality between first class and coach does affect passengers. For example, some planes don't start boarding with their first class passengers. They board from the rear of the aircraft and Keith says that makes a difference. Yeah, there's a difference in the sense that if you board a plane in the middle or at the rear and don't have to walk past the first class cabin, there's a much lower incidence of air rage in the
现在值得注意的是，有头等舱的飞机可能更大，乘客更多，飞行时间更长。更多的人和在空中花费更多的时间也可能增加空中愤怒的可能性。但还有其他迹象表明，看到头等舱和经济舱之间的不平等确实会影响乘客。例如，有些飞机不是从头等舱乘客开始登机。他们从飞机后部登机，基思说这有区别。是的，区别在于，如果你从飞机中部或后部登机，不必走过头等舱，那么在
coach cabin. I remember a scene in the movie, Bridesmaids, Christian Wigg plays a woman named Annie. She's an economy, but all her friends are flying first class. Miss, you cannot be up here. You little grandpa. Mm-hmm. I'm sorry. I just want to be here with my friends,
经济舱中，空中愤怒的发生率要低得多。我记得电影《伴娘》中的一个场景，克里斯汀·韦格饰演一个叫安妮的女人。她在经济舱，但她所有的朋友都在坐头等舱。小姐，你不能待在这里。你这个小老头。嗯哼。对不起。我只是想和我的朋友们在一起，
because I'm with this group. The sign just went off. Can't she stamp a flick of it? Absolutely not. Coach passengers are not allowed up here in first class. It's policy. I'm sorry. Oh, this is a very, this is a very strict blame that I'm on.
因为我和这群人在一起。标志刚刚熄灭。她不能在那儿待一会儿吗？绝对不行。经济舱乘客不允许进入头等舱。这是规定。对不起。哦，这真是一个，这真是一个非常严格的航班。
Welcome to Germany. On futils in. So Keith, of all of Annie's friends or an economy, she would feel a lot better, wouldn't she? Right, the feeling that she deserves to be in first class because her friends are in first class is really powerful because you know if she didn't have any connection to the people in first class, she might pay less attention to them. And so it's that feeling that not only do I not have something that other people have,
欢迎来到德国。在飞机上。所以基思，如果安妮所有的朋友都在经济舱，她会感觉好多了，不是吗？没错，那种她理应坐在头等舱的感觉，因为她的朋友们在头等舱，这真的很强大，因为你知道，如果她和头等舱的人没有任何联系，她可能就不会那么关注他们了。所以，正是那种不仅我没有别人拥有的东西，
but I deserve that thing that other people have that makes that relative comparison so much more painful. Why is it that the comparisons we make are invariably upward comparisons? So if the folks in coach are comparing themselves to the folks in first class, the folks in first class are probably comparing themselves to the folks who fly private jets. There's a pronounced tendency we have to make upward comparisons in all areas of life. And it's not always the case. Sometimes we compare downward or to other people who are similar to us, but we have this pronounced bias to compare upward.
而且我理应拥有别人拥有的东西的感觉，使得这种相对比较变得更加痛苦。为什么我们进行的比较总是向上比较呢？所以如果经济舱的人在和头等舱的人比较，头等舱的人可能在和坐私人飞机的人比较。我们在生活的各个领域都有明显的向上比较的倾向。情况并非总是如此。有时我们向下比较，或者与和我们相似的人比较，但我们有这种明显的向上比较的偏见。
And the reasons for that upward bias are not fully understood, but it seems to have something to do with the fact that upward comparisons on the one hand feel painful because you're comparing to somebody who has something that you don't. But on the other hand, they're also potentially inspiring, potentially motivating, and so they can sort of get you moving to work harder in some cases as well.
这种向上偏见的原因尚不完全清楚，但似乎与这样一个事实有关：一方面，向上比较会让人感到痛苦，因为你在和一个拥有你所没有的东西的人进行比较。但另一方面，它们也具有潜在的启发性和激励性，因此在某些情况下，它们可以让你动起来，更加努力地工作。
So there's something adaptive about it, but also something painful. I remember whenever there's stories in the press about inequality and you read the comment section, you will invariably find someone writing in from New York's Upper West Side, saying a million dollars isn't what you think it is. It really doesn't get you all that much. I'm barely keeping up with all the people around me. But this is how nearly everyone feels at every income level. That's right. And it's incredibly frustrating for ordinary people to read those kind of
所以它既有适应性的一面，也有痛苦的一面。我记得每当媒体上有关于不平等的报道，你阅读评论区时，总会发现有人从纽约上西区写道，一百万美元并不是你想象的那样。它真的买不到那么多东西。我几乎跟不上周围所有人的步伐。但几乎每个人在每个收入水平上都有这种感觉。没错。对于普通人来说，阅读那种
comments. But you can kind of see the psychology at work, right? Because if you're a middle-class person being frustrated at that New Yorker saying that, just think Because if you're a middle class person being frustrated at that, uh, New York or saying that, just think about how you're viewed by other people who are not middle class Americans, either they're people who live in poorer countries around the world or they're people who are struggling to make insmeat in the United States, that same dynamic happens all up and down the income ladder. Now, we increasingly live in a world where you have extremes of inequality.
评论会感到非常沮丧。但你可以看出其中的心理机制，对吧？因为如果你是一个对那个纽约人的说法感到沮丧的中产阶级，试想一下，如果你是一个对那个纽约人的说法感到沮丧的中产阶级，试想一下，那些非中产阶级的美国人是如何看待你的，要么是生活在世界各地较贫穷国家的人，要么是在美国努力维持生计的人，同样的动态在收入阶梯的各个层面都在发生。现在，我们生活在一个不平等现象日益极端的世界上。
The richest, you know, 100 people in the world probably have more wealth than the bottom, maybe the bottom half of the people in the world. Tell me about the title of your book, what do you mean by the broken ladder? One of the images that I used throughout the book to capture the relative differences between people is this idea of a status ladder that we think about ourselves in terms of being on a certain wrong with some people above us and other people below us.
世界上最富有的100个人拥有的财富可能比世界上最底层，也许是底层一半的人拥有的财富还要多。告诉我你书的标题，你所说的“破碎的阶梯”是什么意思？我在整本书中用来捕捉人与人之间相对差异的意象之一，就是这种地位阶梯的概念，我们根据自己在阶梯上的位置来思考自己，有些人高于我们，有些人低于我们。
And where we think we stand on that ladder tells you a lot about a person's life and their life outcomes. And as the scale of inequality gets larger and larger as it's been doing in the United States and other advanced economies around the world, it becomes harder and harder to climb that ladder for a number of reasons. And so when the scale of inequality gets out of proportion to what we can psychologically handle, the ladder is essentially broken. scale of inequality gets out of proportion to what we can psychologically handle. The latter is essentially broken.
我们认为自己站在阶梯的哪个位置，能反映出一个人生活的很多方面及其人生结果。随着不平等的规模越来越大，正如在美国和世界其他发达经济体中所发生的那样，由于多种原因，攀登那个阶梯变得越来越困难。因此，当不平等的规模超出了我们心理上所能承受的范围时，阶梯本质上就断了。不平等的规模超出了我们心理上所能承受的范围。阶梯本质上就断了。
It becomes harder and harder to occupy the wrong that we think we ought to be on. If we go back for a second to that moment in the school lunch cafeteria and something you said back then, which is the moment after the incident was over, you were not objectively poorer than you were a moment before the incident took place, but you felt poorer. In the same way, if you extrapolate that across the whole economy, it might actually be that the poor are not necessarily poorer than they were 50 years ago. They might not have gained very much or even gained anything at all, but they might feel poorer because the rich have gotten so much or even gained anything at all, but they might feel poorer because the rich have gotten so much richer. That's right. If you look at actual income changes over the last 40 or
占据我们认为自己应该占据的位置变得越来越难。如果我们回到学校午餐食堂的那一刻，回到你当时说的话，即事件结束后的那一刻，你并不比事件发生前客观上更穷，但你感觉自己更穷了。同样地，如果你把这一点推演到整个经济中，穷人可能并不一定比50年前更穷。他们可能没有获得太多，甚至什么都没得到，但他们可能会感到更穷，因为富人变得更富了。没错。如果你看看过去40或
50 years, the people in the middle group who might consider middle class incomes haven't made any more or less on average than they did back in the 1960s and 70s. The poorest groups and the middle class groups are basically staying the same, but that stagnation feels like people are falling behind by comparison to the top 20%, the top 10%, and the top 1%, who have made so much more money over the last several decades. So staying in place feels like falling behind if other people are getting so much further ahead. In other words, feelings of opulence and poverty are not merely shaped by objective facts.
50年来的实际收入变化，那些可能被认为是中产阶级收入的中间群体，平均而言并没有比20世纪60年代和70年代赚得更多或更少。最贫穷的群体和中产阶级群体基本保持不变，但这种停滞感让人觉得与前20%、前10%和前1%的人相比，他们正在落后，而这些人过去几十年来赚的钱要多得多。所以，如果其他人领先得太多，原地踏步就感觉像是落后了。换句话说，富裕和贫穷的感觉不仅仅是由客观事实决定的。
Feelings of opulence and poverty are not merely shaped by objective facts. An individual making around $50,000 a year is in the top 1% of all incomes globally. In the United States, people learning that much don't feel like 1%ers. When we come back, how these feelings affect our lives. Keith, tell me what the experience of inequality does to our minds. Tell me about the range of different effects that you and others have identified in terms of what inequality does to the ways our minds work. Inequality does a few different things to the way that both our minds and our bodies respond. One is that it makes us focused on the short term. It makes us impulsive, focused on the here and now. And it makes us more willing to seek out risks
富裕和贫穷的感觉不仅仅是由客观事实决定的。一个年收入约5万美元的人在全球收入中处于前1%。在美国，赚这么多钱的人并不觉得自己是那1%。当我们回来时，我们将探讨这些感受如何影响我们的生活。基思，告诉我，不平等的经历对我们的思想有什么影响。告诉我你和其他人所确定的不平等对我们思维方式影响的范围。不平等对我们的思想和身体的反应方式产生了一些不同的影响。首先，它使我们专注于短期。它使我们变得冲动，专注于当下。它使我们更愿意寻求风险
and engage in high-risk, high-reward sort of gambling behaviors. It also affects our bodies in ways that are similar to physical threats. So the social threat of feeling lower on the status ladder than somebody else provokes very similar reactions physiologically to a physical stressor.
并参与高风险、高回报的赌博行为。它还以类似于身体威胁的方式影响我们的身体。因此，感到自己在地位阶梯上低于他人的社会威胁，在生理上引发了与身体压力源非常相似的反应。
So we react as if we were about to be physically attacked. We react with stress responses as if we were about to face a literal physical challenge. And the total of all of those effects adds up to feeling that we're constantly in crisis. Tell me about the difference in the homicide rate between countries that are equal and countries that are less equal.
所以我们的反应就好像我们要受到身体攻击一样。我们产生的压力反应就好像我们要面对真正的身体挑战一样。所有这些影响的总和加起来，就是一种我们时刻处于危机中的感觉。告诉我平等国家和不平等国家之间凶杀率的差异。
If you look across countries, one of the strong predictors of homicide rates as well as other kinds of violent crime, is the level of income inequality in those countries. Now, we have to make an important distinction here between wealthy developed countries and poorer countries, because in poorer countries, the best predictor of crime and lots of other bad health and social outcomes is actually poverty. Because we're talking about countries in which poor people may not have their basic physical needs met.
如果你观察各个国家，凶杀率以及其他暴力犯罪的一个强有力的预测指标是这些国家的收入不平等水平。现在，我们必须在这里区分富裕发达国家和贫穷国家，因为在贫穷国家，犯罪以及许多其他不良健康和社会结果的最佳预测指标实际上是贫困。因为我们谈论的是那些穷人可能无法满足基本生理需求的国家。
But when we look at wealthy countries like the countries of Western Europe and North America, poverty ceases to be the strong predictor of things like homicide rates and inequality becomes the stronger predictor. Because once people's basic physical needs are met, it becomes the relative comparisons to other people that becomes one of the major stressors that affect people. Now of course it's important to mention that some of these findings are correlations. You're basically looking at patterns, you're not actually conducting an experiment where you're varying how unequal people are and then measuring the outcomes and things like homicide.
但当我们观察西欧和北美等富裕国家时，贫困不再是凶杀率等问题的强预测指标，而不平等成为了更强的预测指标。因为一旦人们的基本生理需求得到满足，与他人的相对比较就成为了影响人们的主要压力源之一。当然，值得一提的是，其中一些发现是相关性。你基本上是在观察模式，你并没有真正进行一项实验，即改变人们的不平等程度，然后测量凶杀等结果。
But tell me about another correlation that people have looked at that has to do with politics, the relationship between inequality and political polarization. If you compare either across countries or within the United States over time, you see a pretty strong correlation between the level of income inequality and the level of political polarization. So it's not that inequality makes people more conservative or more liberal per se, it's that people who are already in those, on those sides, go further into their corners
但告诉我人们观察到的另一个与政治有关的相关性，即不平等与政治极化之间的关系。如果你比较不同国家之间或美国国内随时间的变化，你会发现收入不平等水平与政治极化水平之间存在相当强的相关性。所以并不是说不平等本身使人们变得更保守或更自由，而是那些已经在这些立场上的人，当不平等程度高时，
when inequality is high. What's driving the the fact that people are retreating into their separate camps? There seems to be a back and forth dynamic between how much money people have and what they see around them and how certainly feel in their own opinion. So people who are wealthy tend to feel that they deserve it and they earned it and that tends to make them favor more sort of free market policies and ideologies and people who are struggling who are working hard to get ahead but can't seem to do so tend to feel like the market system is rigged against
会进一步退缩到他们的阵营中。是什么驱动了人们退缩到各自阵营这一事实？人们拥有的金钱、他们周围看到的东西以及他们对自己观点的确定程度之间似乎存在一种来回的动态。所以富人倾向于认为他们理应得到它，他们赚到了它，这往往使他们倾向于更自由的市场政策和意识形态；而那些正在挣扎、努力工作以求进步却似乎无法做到的人，往往觉得市场体系是被操纵的，
them. They favor more progressive taxation and redistribution policies, and both sides tend to think that the system is rigged largely by the other side. And so, the spreading of inequality in terms of money has also spread apart our politics and increased our confidence that we're right and the other side are not only wrong,
对他们不利。他们倾向于支持更进步的税收和再分配政策，双方都倾向于认为这个体系在很大程度上被对方操纵了。因此，金钱方面的不平等蔓延也使我们的政治分歧加剧，并增加了我们对自己正确、而对方不仅错误，
but out to get us. So, you know, as I was preparing for this interview, Keith, I came by this interesting study that Daniel Zizo had conducted. He gave money to volunteers, some got more, some got less, and he found that volunteers were willing to spend their own money If it allowed them to reduce the money that other people had, Zizzo called this burning other people's money And he found that a substantial number of people were willing to reduce their own wealth if they could also reduce the wealth of other people In other words, inequality has such strong
而且一心想对付我们的信心。所以，你知道，在准备这次采访时，基思，我看到了丹尼尔·齐佐进行的一项有趣的研究。他给志愿者钱，有些人得到的多，有些人得到的少，他发现志愿者愿意花自己的钱，如果这能让他们减少别人拥有的钱，齐佐称之为“烧掉别人的钱”，他发现相当多的人愿意减少自己的财富，如果他们也能减少别人的财富。换句话说，不平等有如此强烈的
effects on us that we are willing to make great sacrifices to level the playing field. And from an economic point of view, that's just crazy behavior, right? But from a psychological point of view, it makes perfect sense because we're not judging these things the way an accountant or an economist would, we're thinking thinking what do I have compared to what that other guy has and that relative sense of entitlement and having enough compared to what other people have is so powerful. Keith the researcher is Michael Norton and Dan Ariela once asked volunteers what kind of a country they would like to live in? The first option was a country where the top 20% owned a third of the wealth and the bottom 20% owned 10% of the wealth. Option 2, the top 20% owned 84% of the wealth, the bottom 20% owned 0.1% of the wealth.
影响，以至于我们愿意做出巨大的牺牲来拉平竞争环境。从经济学的角度来看，这简直是疯狂的行为，对吧？但从心理学的角度来看，这完全说得通，因为我们不是像会计师或经济学家那样判断这些事情，我们在思考：与那个人相比，我拥有什么？那种相对的权利感和与他人相比是否拥有足够的财富是如此强大。基思，研究人员迈克尔·诺顿和丹·阿里利曾经问志愿者他们想生活在什么样的国家？第一个选项是前20%的人拥有三分之一的财富，后20%的人拥有10%的财富。选项2，前20%的人拥有84%的财富，后20%的人拥有0.1%的财富。
What do the volunteers say? Most people chose a an overwhelming margin, the more equal option. And of course this was not even a small difference. 92% of Americans apparently chose the first option and that first option doesn't look a lot like America, does it? No, in fact, those pie charts that you just described were taken from actual data, the first one which describes Sweden and the second very unequal one which actually describes the United States. Almost universally, people preferred the first option to the second.
志愿者们怎么说？大多数人以压倒性的优势选择了更平等的选项。当然，这甚至不是一个小差异。显然，92%的美国人选择了第一个选项，而第一个选项看起来并不太像美国，不是吗？不，事实上，你刚才描述的那些饼图是取自实际数据，第一个描述的是瑞典，第二个非常不平等的图表实际上描述的是美国。几乎所有人都普遍更喜欢第一个选项而不是第二个。
The survey, which was conducted in 2005, found that of those who had voted in the last presidential election, 90% of those who voted for a Republican and 94% who voted for a Democrat, said they preferred option 1 to option 2. I ask Keith why this preference for equality doesn't get translated into policy. What explains the mismatch between what we say we want and what we do? Well the important thing in that study was that the charts demonstrating those different levels of inequality were not labeled right and so if you were to add the labels that this is the United States and that Sweden now people would start
这项在2005年进行的调查发现，在上次总统选举中投票的人中，90%的共和党选民和94%的民主党选民表示他们更喜欢选项1而不是选项2。我问基思，为什么这种对平等的偏好没有转化为政策。是什么解释了我们口头上说想要的和我们实际做的之间的不匹配？嗯，那项研究中重要的一点是，展示这些不同不平等水平的图表没有被贴上标签，所以如果你加上标签，说这是美国，那是瑞典，现在人们就会开始
sorting themselves out and choosing the United States or Sweden based on their beliefs. And for those on the right, they see it through largely through a lens of meritocracy where you work for what you get and you deserve whatever that outcome is. Whereas people who are more on the left see it through a lens of fairness and differential starting places. So the gulf there gets mixed up with lots of aspects of our identities and that makes it very difficult to discuss. So let's look at a specific example where perhaps conservatives and liberals would think
根据他们的信仰进行分类，并选择美国或瑞典。对于右翼人士来说，他们主要通过精英管理的视角来看待它，即你为你的所得而工作，你理应得到任何结果。而左翼人士则通过公平和不同起点的地方来看待它。所以那里的鸿沟与我们身份的许多方面混在一起，这使得讨论变得非常困难。那么让我们看看一个具体的例子，也许保守派和自由派会思考
very differently. The baseball player Mike Mike Trout, was recently awarded a contract worth nearly half a billion dollars. Let me ask you, Keith Payne. Do you think the Los Angeles Angels are paying Mike Trout too much? Well, if you look at teams, whether it's baseball or basketball, that have extreme levels of inequality, which are driven by paying superstars, astronomical salaries, they don't outperform other teams that have more equality.
非常不同。棒球运动员迈克·特劳特最近获得了一份价值近五亿美元的合同。让我问你，基思·佩恩。你认为洛杉矶天使队给迈克·特劳特的钱太多了吗？嗯，如果你看看那些存在极端不平等水平的球队，无论是棒球还是篮球，这些不平等是由支付超级巨星天文数字般的薪水驱动的，它们的表现并不优于那些更平等的球队。
And that's counterintuitive if you think that paying the superstars huge salaries means that they're going to work harder and perform better. You would expect better scores and more wins. But in fact, in team sports like that, higher levels of inequality and extreme pay for the superstars is associated with poorer performance and subsequent seasons.
如果你认为支付超级巨星高薪意味着他们会更努力工作、表现更好，这就有违直觉了。你会期望更好的分数和更多的胜利。但事实上，在这样的团队运动中，更高水平的不平等和对超级巨星的极端薪酬与后续赛季表现较差有关。
And of course, this idea might be explained what you said earlier, which is that even if you buy the idea that maybe the superstar does perform very well, the resentment and unfairness that others experience might and come at a cost to the team's performance. That's right, the team coordination seems to be a critical factor here. So extreme disparities like that, overall, tend to be destructive to teamwork and cooperation. So in team sports, that interferes with overall performance. Although in other kinds of sports,
当然，这个想法可能解释了你之前所说的，即即使你相信超级巨星确实表现得非常好，其他人所经历的怨恨和不公平感也可能以牺牲团队表现为代价。没错，团队协调似乎是这里的关键因素。所以这种极端的差异，总体而言，往往对团队合作和协作具有破坏性。因此在团队运动中，这会干扰整体表现。尽管在其他类型的运动中，
like golf or NASCAR racing, where it's just the individual performing their best, their higher stakes, larger pay, do seem to incentivize better performance for the individual. So let's think about what happened to Mike Trout, just a little bit more closely. Let's say that the angels read your book and they decided we want to do away with inequality
比如高尔夫或纳斯卡赛车，这只是个人表现出最佳状态，更高的赌注、更大的报酬似乎确实能激励个人表现得更好。所以让我们更仔细地思考一下迈克·特劳特身上发生的事情。假设天使队读了你的书，他们决定我们想要消除不平等，
and let's take the extreme thought experiment example where they basically said we're going to pay everyone on the team the same amount. We're going to pay everyone, let's say there are 40 players on the team, everyone gets $4 million instead of some people getting $500,000 and some people getting $30 million. Do you think that would be a better outcome? And what kind of problems do you think it would cause if the angels would do that? Well, there are trade-offs here. So probably your highest paid superstars would be very angry at that and maybe they would
让我们采取极端的思想实验例子，他们基本上说我们要给队里的每个人支付相同的金额。假设队里有40名球员，每个人得到400万美元，而不是有些人得到50万美元，有些人得到3000万美元。你认为那会是一个更好的结果吗？如果天使队这样做，你认为会造成什么样的问题？嗯，这里有权衡。所以你薪水最高的超级巨星可能会对此非常生气，也许他们会
leave the team. So that would be a problem. But if you had a more equal level of compensation, it would also increase teamwork and coordination. So that would benefit the team. So in most cases, the argument here is not for absolute equality so that everybody makes the same. It's that, you know, people should be compensated in proportion to their contributions. people should be compensated in proportion to their contributions, but the scale could oftentimes be much more compressed so that the superstar isn't making 30, 40, 50 times what other people are making and could still be compensated in proportion to how much they're bringing to the team.
离开球队。所以那会是一个问题。但如果你有更平等的薪酬水平，它也会增加团队合作和协调。所以这对球队有好处。因此在大多数情况下，这里的论点不是为了绝对平等，让每个人都赚得一样多。而是，你知道，人们应该根据他们的贡献获得报酬。人们应该根据他们的贡献获得报酬，但规模通常可以压缩得多，这样超级巨星赚的钱就不会是其他人赚的30、40、50倍，而且仍然可以根据他们为球队带来的贡献获得报酬。
I want to switch gears just a little bit. The newspaper The Sacramento Bee published the salaries of every California state employee. What happened when people discovered that they were being paid less or more than other people who are working for the state of California? The effects of learning what you made in comparison to what other people made depended on whether you were a higher earner or a lower earner to begin with. So people who were below average when they learned that other people were making much more than them, they felt very dissatisfied. when they learned that other people were making much more than them, they felt very dissatisfied. People who were higher up when they found out how well they were doing compared to other people, ironically it didn't have the same effect. They didn't feel overjoyed at the fact that they were doing so well. Their reaction was just sort of neutral. So they weren't any happier, but the people at the bottom were made more unhappy.
我想稍微转换一下话题。《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》公布了每一位加州州政府雇员的工资。当人们发现他们的工资比其他为加州政府工作的人少或多时，发生了什么？了解自己的收入与他人相比的影响，取决于你最初是高收入者还是低收入者。所以那些低于平均水平的人，当他们得知其他人赚得比他们多得多时，他们感到非常不满。当他们得知其他人赚得比他们多得多时，他们感到非常不满。那些处于高位的人，当他们发现自己与其他人相比做得有多好时，讽刺的是，这并没有产生同样的效果。他们并没有因为自己做得这么好而感到欣喜若狂。他们的反应只是中性的。所以他们并没有更快乐，但底层的人变得更不快乐了。
So when you look at the example of the Sacramento Bee and the publication of the salaries, it raises a question in my head about whether transparency is a good thing or a bad thing. Obviously, as a journalist, I believe that transparency is a good thing, but in this case, if you make salaries transparent and then people end up quitting their jobs and leaving, is that a good outcome? Well, I don't know whether transparency and pay itself is necessarily a good outcome or a bad outcome,
所以当你看看《萨克拉门托蜜蜂报》和工资公布的例子时，它在我脑海中引发了一个问题，即透明度是一件好事还是一件坏事。显然，作为一名记者，我相信透明度是一件好事，但在这种情况下，如果你使工资透明，然后人们最终辞职离开，这是一个好的结果吗？嗯，我不知道工资透明度本身是否一定是一个好的结果或坏的结果，
but what I think transparency shows is the underlying assumptions that we have. So if you think that incentivizing good performance with very high pay is a good thing, then you would want your company to have full transparency. So everybody in the company could see that the superstars were getting paid a lot
但我认为透明度显示了我们所拥有的潜在假设。所以如果你认为用高薪激励良好的表现是一件好事，那么你会希望你的公司有完全的透明度。这样公司里的每个人都能看到超级巨星赚了很多钱，
and that other people weren't getting paid so much and the people who are the poor performers are getting paid very poorly. If your idea is that pay and equity increases performance, you should want total transparency. And yet what we have is a system in which most companies, most organizations want to keep their pay and equality secret. And then social norms are not to talk about these things, which means that at some level, we must kind of know that there's something else going on besides just incentivizing good performance. We know at some level that
而其他人赚得没那么多，表现差的人赚得非常少。如果你的想法是薪酬公平能提高表现，你应该想要完全的透明度。然而我们拥有的是一个大多数公司、大多数组织想要对薪酬不平等保密的体系。然后社会规范是不谈论这些事情，这意味着在某种程度上，我们一定知道除了激励良好表现之外还有其他事情在发生。我们在某种程度上知道
there's this negative feeling surrounding talking about differences in pay and that that's likely to have some bad outcomes as well. When you looked at the example of the aircraft studies that you told me about at the start of our conversation, you mentioned that in aircraft that do not board passengers from the front or aircrafts that don't have first-class cabin at all, you have fewer of these problems. Now, of course, you're going to have rich people and slightly less rich people on those airplanes as well, but the differences are not visible and those differences therefore don't translate into some of the problems that you are describing. It raises the question again, if you have inequalities in a society, an organization, a community, are we better off making them
围绕谈论薪酬差异存在这种负面情绪，而且这很可能也会带来一些坏结果。当你观察我谈话开始时提到的飞机研究例子时，你提到在那些不从前部登机乘客的飞机，或者根本没有头等舱的飞机上，你遇到的这些问题较少。当然，那些飞机上也会有富人和稍微没那么富的人，但差异是不可见的，因此这些差异不会转化为你所描述的一些问题。这再次引发了一个问题，如果你在一个社会、组织、社区中存在不平等，我们最好让它们
visible or better off keeping them invisible? It's a good question. There's no simple answer because on the one hand, when people are economically segregated and you have the wealthy living behind gated communities and very separate from the way ordinary people are living and the way poor people are living, it might be psychologically easier on the middle class and the poor people not to see that. But on the other hand, it creates a greater feeling of distance between the haves and have knots and less of a feeling of community.
可见，还是最好让它们不可见？这是一个好问题。没有简单的答案，因为一方面，当人们在经济上被隔离，富人住在封闭式社区后面，与普通人的生活方式和穷人的生活方式非常隔绝时，对于中产阶级和穷人来说，看不到这一点在心理上可能更容易。但另一方面，它在富人和穷人之间创造了更大的距离感，而社区感则更少。
And you know, that leads to increased polarization and lower levels of trust. So there's no simple answer in terms of whether we want highly visible or highly transparent inequality versus less visible and less transparent inequality because there's always a trade-off at work between what feels good versus what has negative consequences down the road. Your psychologist's Keith, and you know that there are several small warehouses filled with studies that show that comparing ourselves to others is often a recipe for unhappiness. It's clear that at a societal level, we need to sort of take heed of the lessons of inequality, the psychological consequences of inequality.
你知道，这导致了极化加剧和信任水平降低。所以关于我们是想要高度可见或高度透明的不平等，还是想要不太可见和不太透明的不平等，没有简单的答案，因为在什么感觉良好与什么在未来产生负面后果之间，总是存在权衡。你是心理学家，基思，你知道有几个装满研究的小仓库显示，将自己与他人比较往往是导致不快乐的秘诀。显然，在社会层面，我们需要注意不平等的教训，不平等的心理后果。
Does it also translate to the individual level, our individuals better off thinking about inequality or better off not thinking about it? I think there's not really any option of not thinking about it because we're constantly making social comparisons to what others have around us to define what's normal and what's enough. But I think there are wiser and less wise ways to think about inequality and to make those social comparisons.
它是否也转化为个人层面，个人最好思考不平等，还是最好不要思考它？我认为没有不思考它的选项，因为我们不断地与周围其他人拥有的东西进行社会比较，以定义什么是正常的，什么是足够的。但我认为有更明智和不太明智的方式来思考不平等并进行那些社会比较。
So one of the things I recommend in the book is that we can be more strategic in making upward versus downward social comparisons. We talked earlier about how people tend to, by default, make upward social comparisons to those who have more than them. But we can strategically make downward social comparisons also, right? So instead of just thinking about what other people have who have more than us, we can remind ourselves that, you know, there are a lot of people around who have less than us. And upward and downward social comparisons have opposite consequences.
所以我在书中推荐的一件事是，我们在进行向上与向下社会比较时可以更具策略性。我们之前谈到人们默认倾向于与那些比自己拥有更多的人进行向上社会比较。但我们也可以策略性地进行向下社会比较，对吧？所以与其只思考那些比我们拥有更多的人拥有什么，我们可以提醒自己，你知道，周围有很多人比我们拥有得少。向上和向下社会比较有相反的后果。
Upward social comparisons, as I mentioned before, feel terrible, but they can be motivating. Downward social comparisons feel great, and yet they can be demotivating. So it depends on what your goal is. Do you want to take a break from feeling stressed? Well, then do some downward social comparison. Do you want to feel motivated and energized to go out and do more, do some upward social comparisons? So neither one is good in itself. It's just that we can be more mindful about the kinds of comparisons we're making on a daily basis. Keith Bain is a psychologist at the University of North Carolina. He's the author of the
向上社会比较，正如我之前提到的，感觉很糟糕，但它们可以起到激励作用。向下社会比较感觉很好，但它们可能会让人失去动力。所以这取决于你的目标是什么。你想从压力感中休息一下吗？那么做一些向下社会比较。你想感到有动力和精力去走出去做更多的事情吗？那么做一些向上社会比较。所以两者本身都不是好的。只是我们可以对我们每天进行的比较类型更加留心。基思·佩恩是北卡罗来纳大学的心理学家。他是
Broken Ladder, How Inequality Effects the Way We Live, Think and Die. Keith, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much. This week's show was produced by Path Shal. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Thomas Liu, Laura Quarral and Jenny Schmitt. includes Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell and Jenny Schmidt. Our unsung hero today is Keith Woods. Keith is Vice President of Newsroom Training and Diversity at NPR. He's helped establish NPR's training program, creating opportunities for journalists to learn more about the craft of storytelling.
《破碎的阶梯：不平等如何影响我们的生活、思考和死亡》的作者。基思，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。本周的节目由帕斯·沙尔制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和珍妮·施密特。包括托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和珍妮·施密特。我们今天的无名英雄是基思·伍兹。基思是NPR新闻编辑室培训和多元化副总裁。他帮助建立了NPR的培训项目，为记者创造了更多了解讲故事技巧的机会。
Keith is the epitome of the inclusive leader, always ready to share his thoughts or to lend a hand. Thanks Keith. If you liked this episode, please share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
基思是包容性领导者的典范，总是乐于分享他的想法或伸出援手。谢谢你，基思。如果你喜欢这一集，请与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。